I heard about what eita
very early in my childhood from the age
of five onwards so it was one of the
earliest things I started to read when I
started to read and it was very much
part of my consciousness in the
beginning I saw the Bhagavad Gita's text
that was very classical much like the
Iliad and the Odyssey mythical saga that
showed the eternal conflict between good
and evil but much later as I grew up I
realized that it was much more than that
it was it was an examination of
consciousness and the desire of human
beings of the quest that we have as
human beings to understand ourselves
that it was the map you might say for
exploring the territory and that leads
us to find out things about herself who
are we where do we come from was the
meaning and purpose of our existence do
we have a soul what happens to us after
we die does God exist does God in fact
care about us how can we get in touch
with that source that we call
consciousness is the consciousness
behind our thoughts also the
consciousness responsible for all the
intelligent activity of the universe the
bhagavad-gita is actually a very good
text for yoga the yoga of love the yoga
of action or karma the yoga of
understanding or intellect and the yoga
of reflection and meditation so I think
it's a very important map for
understanding the nature of
consciousness the word yoga is the same
as the English word yoke
so in the New Testament when Jesus
Christ says my yoke is easy and my
burden is light my interpretation is
that he's referring to yoga it means
Union union of the body mind and the
spirit as one continuum of consciousness
I think about what Gita is about both
the forces of light and the forces of
darkness that exists within our own self
within our own soul that our deepest
nature is one of ambiguity we have
evolutionary forces there
forces of creativity and love and
compassion and understanding but we also
have darkness inside us the diabolical
forces of separation fear and delusion
and in most of our lives there's a
battle going on within ourselves between
the sacred and the profane between the
evolutionary impulses and destructive
tendencies and that we have between
creativity on the one hand and addictive
behavior on the other hand between the
divine and the diabolical between the
light and the shadow between the sacred
and the profane so the bhagavad-gita is
an understanding of this battle that we
have in our consciousness that
ultimately is played out in the
battlefield that we call our physical
bodies in the physical universe so by
understanding the dynamics of these
forces within our own consciousness and
by beginning to harmonize our impulses
with the evolutionary impulse within us
we heal ourselves and in doing so we
heal not only our physical bodies but
our world because the world that we find
ourselves in is a projection both of our
personal consciousness and our
collective consciousness so I think it's
very relevant to modern times when
see things like global warming and
climate chaos and changing weather
patterns and natural disasters like
Hurricane Katrina and extreme poverty
and economic disparities and social
injustice and war and terrorism these
are the projection of a collective
consciousness that's in disarray a very
collective consciousness where there is
a rift in the collective soul a
collective consciousness that is
evolving but is going through a lot